welcome to this video war gasm again and
got this guy quite often as an opponent
okay I'm playing again a French defense
by request let's see hmm
castling not that I never saw it I saw
castling before there is castles and
night a3 in this position as far as I
remember and I really have forgotten
anything okay
so he wants to okay maybe he wants to
trade the bishop here and then play
Knight to b5 but I have a six right it's
not it shouldn't be that terrible trade
with the dark squared bishop in fact can
sometimes be an issue because of his
vulnerability for porn okay so he really
really really really is convinced that
night b5 is strong yeah I mean he's
basically killed his King side structure
for the night coming to the 6 so let's
see okay I can go to c7 but this would
be a perpetual so I mean might be
five-year we repeat and I don't want to
repeat because I actually think that
this should be quite good for black
my ideas g5 and he completely ignores
what I'm doing here probably hmm
I thought you five would be good
isn't that good g5f 595 24 heads it's a
slightly open King position yeah yeah
also King go age five age five I mean
okay age five he cannot take and he has
to play age three now maybe the night
over to g6 is also an idea to check to
attack the weaknesses here
and that I didn't think of it all
yeah diffic difficult not to take nokia
so yeah I didn't prove that this was
really bad what he did I did not prove
that I feel I should should have had
some some some possibility to do it but
I didn't didn't see it I didn't see
anything remotely like a refutation or
something something like that try to get
rid of us tonight it's difficult yeah
it's difficult go night of seven over
here yeah maybe King g7 night of 7s
still still possible it for maybe you
know it's not doing that
hmm yeah I was I wanted to go night f7
ready yeah come on I have to get rid of
this night there should be six I check
on d6 and then Luke is six and I look f6
sorry I can just take the five wow I
totally overlooked that I could you can
just take the five here not good
yeah well it's not it's not directly
lost or anything three he has okay
that's not funny playing this this
Watson endgame here
yeah the only hope is a very reduced
material okay
it just allows me to take here
surprisingly if I take now there yeah
well this is a draw really I will manage
that I guess unless I'm blundering it
sounds very stupid stuff but other than
that it is really ad wrong look see six
I will just take on g5 and there's
nothing to do there from watch
hmm what did I do wrong interesting the
timing of f6 maybe somewhere around that
that's a very strange way to play for
winter going to look and game around and
there is really no way to to anything
here right let's just look at it briefly
I can't read I mean it's it's a draw
anyway I mean you just just play some
some stupid moves or some Williams that
are not necessary really
is it wrong you can do whatever you want
yeah it's it's just so drawn hmm
I really would have liked to refute that
it looked strange to me here it is f5f
far if I have to do okay that's
interesting
that's interesting the the reason is
then I have this move now and this looks
nice okay soaps yeah and this is really
what I was hoping for yeah this is
really nice now this is weak and
something like that is exploding in in
records time at f4 yeah it was he has to
do that it's not rocket science this
move but it's it all of a sudden it
wasn't that bad absolutely not no yeah
g5 was the alternative but I had some I
had some doubts yeah
after at 590 X Queen d4 or something
like that I don't know hey look it looks
very very loose I was afraid of that but
knight c6 seems to be good I didn't
really see something
concrete yeah but I had a bad feeling
about it so I went with age five but
this is not really really doing anything
great Jim yeah here you meet him
maintains an advantage she's just more
active and what I really didn't see was
that yeah I'm kind of tied up yeah this
is this is one of the one of the better
end games that that could have could
have popped up but he relatively quickly
don't understand here I mean I want to
stop fish giving here I have five yeah
okay if I ever understand
I should have prevented that but why is
it giving so 1.5 in this position I mean
this is really this is really really
really drawing Jason this and a five and
stocked fish says white is almost
winning what What nonsense is that this
is just a draw this is just a drawing
why wouldn't it be a draw I don't get it
really takes takes and then somewhere
here the apron this is still an apron on
the port I mean without the eight points
it's it's totally dead yeah we don't
even need to continue then but
you
now here White has chances definite
chance he can put the rope here which
covers both weaknesses then he can try
to run over with the King yeah I
understand the aprons make make a huge
difference
they make a huge difference so well this
and if I do it like that you're getting
four takes takes maybe if I can get
behind the pawn like here if jack check
look here
but the King invades no this is really
bad that's still a critical endgame yeah
I'm sorry I was too optimistic here this
was too optimistic I was still suffering
here in this position this is what we
played actually and he's still at f5 and
here it's really a wrong yeah this was a
little bit strange but it is really just
totally dead yeah I mean we don't even
have to you can can draw this with
whatever move okay well thanks for
watching